with a steady stream of coronavirus dead
speed is of the essence at the morgue
every morning the team from the funeral
agency ufarritual comes here to collect
new victims of the pandemic
twenty-nine-year-old arthur kinsey kev
has been working at the funeral home for
12 years
but he says he's never had to bury this
many bodies
in such a difficult time a lot depends
on the team we all know exactly what to
do
we know who picks up the coffin from
which side which shoulder to carry it on
that makes a difference how we work
together matters even more now
that we have so much work
call the relatives to identify the body
this morgue in the city of wufa is only
for those who died of the coronavirus or
had contact with an infected person
the bodies have to be sealed in plastic
the coffins closed
many russians feel their dead should be
treated with more respect
artur explains
the relatives are often more tense than
usual because their dead are handed over
to
them in plastic body bags they aren't
allowed
to open the bags i tell them that right
away
some people cry and demand that we open
the bags
then i have to explain that they could
get infected themselves
the virus is no joke
yuri kazloff has been in the business
for seven years
today he's in charge of the team of
undertakers he says that since the
second wave of coronavirus hit
in the fall there have been more than
twice as many deaths in the city of
buffalo
everyone i know suddenly wants to know
more about our work
they call me and ask are there really so
many funerals
are a lot of people dying i tell it to
them like it is
people don't believe the media maybe
they think they are being lied to
so instead they want first-hand
information and they ask
us over a million people live in ufa
the capital of the republic of
bashkurstan government statistics say
that only around
80 people in the region have died of the
coronavirus since the pandemic began
but official numbers also show that
during that time
over 4 000 more people died than in the
same period last year
coronavirus infections are spiking
across russia
but authorities insist the situation is
under control
the undertakers aren't so sure today
yuri kazlof and his team are entering a
92 year old woman
she didn't die of the coronavirus that
means her relatives can say their final
farewell with an open casket
which is the tradition in russia
usually funerals are big family affairs
in russia
people gather at the cemetery and then
at home with food and long toasts
but the pandemic has changed that
some people call to express their
condolences instead of going to the
funeral
some people are afraid of getting
infected they don't want to take the
risk
some people are really worried about
what is happening but we have to bury
people anyway
no matter what happens
since the coronavirus some funeral
agencies have even started offering live
streams from the cemetery
business is booming so far
no one on yuri's team has caught kovid
he can only hope
it will stay that way
in russia people say if it's decided up
there that you'll get run over by a
streetcar
you won't drown fate is fate if the
coronavirus isn't my fate
it will pass me by
the next day the team prepares for four
more funerals
artur and his colleagues hardly have
time to worry about their own health
at the moment they're just too busy
you